c'est le président mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des Transports monsieur le
ministre la France connaît aujourd'hui
des grèves parmi les grévistes figurent
les aiguillières du rail ce déo de
France aujourd'hui mais ce d'Occitanie
les ont précédés au printemps leur
doléances est simple il réclame des
embauches parce que notre système est
totalement obsolète il faut encore des
personnes physiques pour assurer
l'aiguillages des trains sur ce sujet de
modernisation du rail nous avons 40 ans
de retard
moderniser notre rail c'est mettre en
place de nouveaux systèmes de
signalisation à commencer par le système
européen de gestion du trafic
ferroviaire c'est aussi regrouper la
gestion des 2200 aiguillages dans 16
postes de commande centralisée du réseau
digitalisé
c'est enfin numériser le système de
gestion de transport pour combler cette
lacune un énorme effort d'investissement
doit être consenti aujourd'hui
c'est à dire au pire moment puisque
parallèlement la flambée du coude
l'électricité plombe les dépenses de
fonctionnement des autorités
organisatrices de transport à l'exemple
en Île-de-France ce surcourt représente
950 millions d'euros pour boucler le
budget 2023 l'essentiel de cette somme
n'étant pas financée le spectre
récemment agité d'un passe Navigo
augmenté à 100 euros inquiète je le dis
ici car je sais que nous partageons tous
ce point il n'est évidemment pas
question de pénaliser davantage les
usagers
dans ces conditions il est légitime de
craindre un effet de vaste communicant
entre des choix d'investissement et de
fonctionnement ce dernier phagocytan le
premier ce faisant c'est aussi une
remise en cause de notre chemin vers la
neutralité carbone car le report modal
sur le train est un axe clé de la
stratégie gouvernementale aussi Monsieur
le Ministre avez-vous identifié une
telle menace et comment comptez-vous y
répondre d'un point de vue budgétaire